as jake woodford will get the start for
the cardinals
in this game number 162.
it's been kind of a wild ride for him
this year too the hyundai pitch arsenal
it's had a very good month of september
an era under two he's had been in five
games and four of them starts
looped out to left there's o'neill one
away
schwendel hitting 322
this one drilled left field o'neal back
and that one is off the wall
and frank schwendell has himself a
double
now it's time for the cubs cleanup
hitter matt
duffy and that's a base hit into right
field they're going to send schwendel
carlson up with it and the throw is too
late rbi single
matt duffy comes through and it's one
nothing
it's sharply to short taken there by
sosa
and he makes the play
happening in the books in game 162 one
nothing chicago alec mills
feature a sinker at 89 four seamer
change up slider and a curveball we like
to call that the dumper big slow when he
flips up there at 66 miles per hour but
a rough go of late for
alec she faces edmond goldsmith and
o'neal in the bottom of the first
tommy edmond get up baby get up get up
oh yeah
it's a leadoff homer for tommy edmond
and well done tommy edmond on the first
pitch he sees well that's a sinker
didn't sink
they play the shift with o'neill up here
chases that time at a strikeout
that's out to short alcantara takes it
in
and throws them out
so mills after allowing the lead off
homer gets the next three end of one
it's one one
two on
erica castello he's our catcher
ground ball shoshone
and the turn
safe at first
one ball and two strikes on alec mills
and that'll be the first strikeout for
woodford coming up carlson molina sosa
and we're tied 1-1 runners at the
corners the 2-0 pitch to sosa
ground ball sharply hit to short run
will score and they will get the double
play mike schiltz not so sure about that
out at first base but a run scores
mccartney
frank schwendell at the plate
and he strikes out second today for jake
woodford two strikeouts for jake
woodford and woodford will go after ian
happy
case and that's three today for woodford
packed house here at bush
and st louis on top
so here's the veteran matt carpenter
rough season for the 35 year old
schwendel
and mills gets over that is a good
looking double play three six one and
they turn that nicely
cardinals have a two to one lead and
their lead off better is matt duffy
wow what a play here what a play tommy
edmond ranging to his right
as duffy is out 4-3
on a sliding acrobatic play by tommy
edmond i'll put a star on that one
just like her old friend the late jerry
coleman of the padres
and from his knees tommy threw
accurately to first base to retire duffy
in a high fly ball lifted out to left
o'neal under it has it
woodpert is through four
it'll be o'neill rondon and carlson
coming up in a 2-1 game two outs and two
on
on the ground duffy will beat rondon to
third and that ends the inning
the picture is going to be uh
tyler payne
check swing and he went
so payne strikes out in his major league
debut
so a two-out single for rafael and it'll
bring up the tank frank schwendell
here's the 0-1 schwendel swings and
lines one fair ball down the left field
line it'll roll all the way to the wall
ortega rounds third he's coming home
here comes the throw
and ortega scores easily tie ball game
frank schwendell evens it up
2-2 cubs and cardinals here in the fifth
minute first and second for the cubs
here in the top half of the fifth inning
and it'll bring up the cubs cleanup man
matt duffy
base hit up the middle
and duffy with the knock
schwindel coming in to score
and the cubs have the lead it's now 3-2
and now it's trace thompson runners at
the corners for chicago
[Applause]
runner goes kisner's throw
it's by design and a rundown
last time we saw this
it was the play of the year
they work that to perfection
jack flaherty is second relief
appearance
yeah this is is this two or three oh
that's right the one was
an opener yeah so it's his second relief
appearance this year and
here's the numbers for flaherty
held on to by kisner with the tag of
thompson and flaherty records a
strikeout jim broney is over two
swank and a miss and he struck him out
a couple of strikeouts in the inning for
jack flaherty midway through six and the
cubs lead at 3-2 joe bianchini to jose
rondon
that will line and caught nice play by
jim broney
and he shows it to the second base
umpire greg gibson
sinking line drive and jim burnley got a
real nice break on it two down here's
molina
up towards left center dikeman got a
good jump
and biagini able to get them one two
three
two gone two on let's see if biagini can
get out of this jam
in the air but softly hit
thompson has it
and biagini able to pitch around the
walk and the hit batter comes still lead
at the end of seven it's 3-2
and i believe they're going to tell the
players to get off the field now no
reason to risk
injury at this point in time so the
umpires are going to have them get off
the field as reyes was getting loose to
come in this ball game and the grounds
crew yet again is the game over
or are they what are they doing
oh he's got to officially declare it
he's going to
his last act as a major league umpire
he's going to declare this game has been
officially banged comes one at 3-2